a chicken made out of eggshells and
locked and loaded it's episode 27 of IMG
this guy loves dogs and this guy hates
his son by Topsy a brought us angry bat
Birds complete with Robin Alfred the
Joker
bane and use lipstick to make a panda
Pikachu this little cutie a bee or a
crab those are extreme makeovers but
here's an extreme make out of course the
secret to getting girls to make out with
you is having a six-pack or maybe just
pick up some of these custom contact
lenses featured on Adi comm Hello Kitty
Mickey Mouse smiley faces spider webs or
this one which actually hangs crystals
from your eyeball with medical liar
Adi also featured subdermal implants
they're like tattoos but
three-dimensional you can make pokeballs
Braille brass knuckles head spikes horns
or the most badass of them all ice cream
and cupcakes but nothing can be
photoshopped
take a celebrity and then take away
their eyebrows nice James Franco Arnold
Schwarzenegger Justin Bieber Sarah
Jessica Parker and Robert Pattinson now
here's a website for people with a
headphone fetish which means it's a
perfect time for a montage of celebrity
armpits
I'm just kidding let's do babies at
Hooters enjoy
oh hey there BuzzFeed showed us guitars
the five the sword the Millennium Falcon
the Picasso and um this one baby
changing station or baby grilling
station and this is one dinosaur of a
spill now on facebook.com slash Vsauce
gaming summer showed us Bieber gone wild
and Mahmud exposed to the world's
creepiest shoes I leave you today with
cats winning in episode 22 of IMG I
asked you guys to help me put leader
clothes on celebrities I sees a you
recommended lingerie on Charlie Sheen
and so I made this just for you this
week let's combine weird celebrity body
parts to create one mutant celebrity
leave your suggestions in the comments
below and if I love it I'll make it and
schapp you out on IMG be sure to
subscribe to vsauce for more and as
always thanks for watching
you